[Music]
so we got gt
we got palmer penguins
now we got the dataset penguins pipe
down to gt
and in your viewer you get the table
which is pretty sweet you have to do too
much just to get a basic table right
so i'm just going to move this out a bit
so you can actually see more of the
table great great
so um
say you wanted to do things like
make this look nice like you add a title
because tails are nice because it tells
you what's going on the table so we can
actually do that by the tab header
and then
there's an option right there you just
see in like the pop-up help title
subtitle seems to be optional i like a
subtitle sometimes but i'll put in title
i'll put it in
penguin's data
all right and so we could just run like
that as it is
but
we have this cool thing called markdown
so we can actually use that too
you just have to wrap this with md
and you can do cool things like
use markdown
and now we can have like
these back ticks to
say like this is going to be like in
this code font
and there we go
instantly you can just sort of like you
know work iteratively and see the result
on the side
and this is kind of nice because you can
sort of like learn how to make tables
and and when it comes to like uh
the time to like publish these tables
another markdown document or quarter
document
um you've already you know practiced it
this just becomes second nature so yeah
tab header that easy titles let's
actually put a subtitle because that's
kind of sweet uh subtitle we want to use
markdown because it's a good thing
so what's something we can say about the
penguins data set three years
three years
of data
that's not bad uh on
penguins
on
three islands we can make this long
because the the subtitle is pretty small
so we're using markdown uh what's not
let that go to waste uh so let's
actually accentuate something here
oh yeah but with two asterisks on each
side of three we can make that bold
and just for fun and just to prove that
it works we can do this in italics so
let's run this whole thing
not too shabby uh so we get like the
markdown treatment here it just appears
and by default it's just centered
um i mean that's a cool thing we can
also make it left aligned if you want
that that's like you know we can get
that a little bit later
never mind let's do it now because no
timeline
so opt
uh table
align table header okay great so now we
just have to say align equals left
for that sort of nice left aligned look
actually that looks more pro than before
actually for some reason
i really like it okay so that is how to
make a title like a header on a table so
now we're saying like
now we're thinking like
okay we have all this data that's a lot
for a summary table let's actually just
make a summary table right because this
is a
this is not the true lines it's
basically just like raw data in
lots of ways so
the cool thing is we have things like
the tidy burst like d plier tidy r all
that stuff i'm just going to load in the
time universe
great
and we can do stuff to penguins before
we you know put in the gt so we can do
things like
all the fun stuff like group by
we can group by uh
maybe species let's do that
okay great
and then we'll do a summarize
uh here's the thing i don't know what
the summaries how about like these are
like the
mean body mass
and mean just means we'll just do some
means means everywhere
fine let's just do one uh
and then let's see if this
works with funds
whoa whoa okay good
going with it
maybe
so we have to do
okay so let's move this back to where it
was
and there's like an n a oh yeah it's
sort of like the mean
it's gonna be like this
i'm totally not sure if that's gonna
work that totally works okay good okay
so we're doing this
so we can do mean i'm not sure how you
do multiple functions i think it might
be list
um
i'm not sure if you just put you know
what i'm not gonna follow with that i'm
just gonna like put a bunch of bars here
and
away we go
okay so we'll do build length uh fill
depth
great
so
uh let's do
flipper
yeah we just
we'll make it a bunch of things like
that
i mean i'd probably say like
just the indices like three to like
i like to make things hard for myself
okay that's a flipper
no matches seriously
okay
okay and now body pass g
great i think that'll do it okay so now
we got this
excellent so now we have a summary table
okay so now we got this this is kind of
cool so we have
um
our summary table which is up here let
me make this a little bit bigger
you can't see it all
and we have species and we have
you know all the data
involved the cool thing about gt is it
allows you to put things like in a stub
so these are kind of like labels for a
row uh so we could do something called
rhodium call
and we can put species in there like
that column name
and the great thing about that is that
it just sets it off puts it to the left
and sets it off with an automatic order
and there's nothing about that either
which you can change uh but it's nice
because you can just like have this as
like it looks more like a table
then it you know just it being like not
suffering like that
so we do that with her name call equal
species
uh so this is still cool uh we can
actually change the title so it's like
summary of the english dsm it's actually
a little more interesting
uh and we cannot you know this is no
longer
valid i don't think three years of data
on
i would say like maybe uses
three years of data on penguins
on three elements maybe that's a bit
more
correct uh to say so now if we run this
whole thing
let me make this
bigger okay great remember this whole
thing
so now we get this uses three years of
data and we can always change things
like the title like so
run it again pretty quickly
so now we sort of see the beginnings of
a nicer table uh the only problem we
have is
the the column labels look not so great
i mean they're great for like you know
like your your tables and deep fire uh
but they're not so great for like
summary tables
other people so we can make those nice
uh we can totally do that with uh
something
called calls
labels
okay
so if we do
bill
length
and then put equal sign
then in quotes the thing you want to
change it to that works and you just
like have a bunch of those like sort of
set off like it's like a list
essentially without having a list around
it so we can just say uh bill length
and the cool thing is we can do things
like
this
and put in mm below
let's see if i can if i'm right about
that um so i'm going to tie this all
together with that
no okay not quite the thing we have to
do is put md around it because the br
tag is html
and markdown it recognizes html so
that's a sort of a good pairing
there we go so now we have bill length
millimeters we probably want a comma
as we often see
would be nice to start separating those
things apart so now we have build length
mm and it looks a bit nicer it's a bit
more narrow which is great and we can do
the same thing for the rest uh so we
just have to of copy this as a template
work down
change it so now we're going to change
depth here
depth
and then just become depth
uh same sort of things apply add commas
repeat them
and
next one would be flipper length
great and one more body mass g okay
okay
er
and then g
great let's see how it looks just by
like uh writing all this code
not bad it's looking pretty good it's
looking more table like a little bit
less you know like wide
uh so these are just some cool things to
do the numbers we probably don't need
that many digits like after you know
after a decimal point
that's a lot uh so gt comes with a whole
ton of like these formatting functions
they all begin with fmt so you see a few
of them here the thing you really want
here is format number
which has just a plethora of options
that you can use so we'll go with that
and just by using the defaults it's like
two digits after decimal place all the
way down
and it operates on columns so you need
to have that absolutely and the cool
thing is you can borrow things from
dpplier that's how you first you can use
everything
uh because all the columns here that are
in like the data are numeric so we
totally use that
great another cool thing about it is
that uh if you use format number it
comes with these it uses these uh digit
separators basically commas
and uh that just gets put in where it
needs to be put in uh automatically
that's kind of cool
and
another cool thing is that
this might not be what you want body
mass g maybe you want kilograms
uh so we can we can actually do that so
we can put another formatter function in
which is for my number again
and we can target just the body mass
column
so to do that we
use just like the original column name
like this body mass g
like so but now we're gonna use options
we're gonna do something a little bit
more interesting we're going to do
something use an option called scale by
in this case we want in kilograms so
we're going to scale it by
one over one thousand
so we're going to divide by fast
cool so let's do that
now we have it in kilograms so we're
going to go back
change the label to be kg
and
this is kind of nice because like you
know it takes all those digits sort of
compresses it down to like something's a
bit more readable we have less digits
overall
and you know if you're starting with g
you might you might as well go to kg
like it's not a stretch of imagination
so you can actually scale numbers with
the formatters in gt which is kind of
cool
um now we have this
we may notice like there's a few things
that are kind of like not great um
like for one thing this probably just
bothers me but like the width of these
columns is not the same
um you know across
it's basically governed by like the
width of like the largest label uh in
this case flipper length makes the
column much more wider but we can we can
change that we can change anything uh we
can go to use this function called calls
with
right there
and what we can do is we can select the
columns
i believe it's going to be um
okay uh
you can use tie select on the left side
so we can do things like
okay so we can use this right here we
can use just as far as list i think
okay like so
i'm gonna bring that down
like this because we just need the names
itself not in quotes
oh i apologize uh we actually
oh sorry those are the original names
so we get like this
and then on the right side we're going
to put in
a width value so we can use this px
helper function if you want
it just means that any value put there's
a few pixels it's the same thing as
writing like in quotes some number with
px to the right of it
uh so let's put in like 50
to see where it starts and we'll just
copy that down to each of these
so
and see what it gives us
no okay so i got that wrong instead of
equal signs we should be using this
great
okay let's try this out
okay not bad i mean
a little bit small but the cool thing is
we can stretch this out so we made this
80 for instance
and then we'll get it to like you know a
width that's kind of nice
oh not quite right let's make this even
bigger 120 i think
there we go and we might even like bring
it down a bit it's it's all like
iterative you're going to like adjust
things as you go luckily it's pretty
fast
there's you know there's almost no time
cost
i think we missed the sweet spot here i
think it's gonna be like 110 or
thereabouts or like things stop wrapping
maybe 120 was good
okay i'm gonna go with this this is not
bad so now we have like all the columns
like at least in the data part being
like you know of
the same width which is kind of nice it
kind of leaves your eye like and
in a nice way like each of these numbers
are spaced out the same over space
between them which is kind of cool
uh and you can also do the same thing
for this tab as well you can just use
the very end everything
and that means in this case everything
else and we can make that a bit bigger
i'm not sure what it's starting at but
if you just do 60
it's definitely going to change things
and i'm going the wrong direction
maybe we want that to be 100
and there we are
so now we have the ideas
our table
uh with the widths that we want so we
basically focusing on presentation here
and we're trying to make it look good i
guess uh but these are tricks you can do
pretty simply
uh you just have to and of course you
use high select here if you have like a
statement that works nicely for all
these four columns
that works um
you definitely use on the left side
there and just use px equals 120 for all
of them
uh so that's that
so say you want to like add some notes
um
and you know we add a header section but
what about a footnote section so we can
definitely have that and there's two
ways to put stuff in the footer we can
use tab source node
great these are just general notes that
you pop in to the bottom
and
you know a good thing we can say here
or put in is like where the dataset
comes from
okay so dataset
is package
and we can just save our package as well
and put a period
earning a little bit of space so i'm
going to just line right here
and we can try that
out but i know it's gonna be a mistake
and the mistake is that we're using
markdown
when really uh we didn't declare it so
in all these parts all these like
opportunities put in text we can
definitely use mark like empty helper
function and it just means interpret
this as markdown
and
any output format you use
will render that
uh to be looking nice like the way you
want it to look
and we might even do a thing like
century r just like this
sort of inside of it
there we go
so that's just like a source node
basically it's a node that's not
tied into any particular place in the
table
uh but we can do that we can use tab
and this takes in like two arguments uh
so in the previous one you just have to
put in like a note
in this case you have to put in like the
note
plus what location the note was
referring to so let's add the footnote
first
and i guess now's a good time to talk
about what we're going to actually point
out we can just say like gentoo
uh looks to be like the biggest
penguin
by most accounts i mean um
not so much in build length and bill
death but certainly flipper length and
body mass
you know gen 2 is like reign supreme i
guess i'm on c3 so we can just do that
but just say like gen 2 is largest
i'll just say the largest
of the three
penguins
study
great so
that's great that's the note that's
going to appear at the bottom
so we're going to attach this to i mean
the most logical place in in my mind
would be like the label itself or gen 2
right here so in this step
so in locations
we can use like this huge amount of like
location helper functions
and they all begin with cells
and you see the auto pop that's really
the auto help shows us give us a guide
as to which ones are available
in this case we want cell step so it's
going to appear a little bit lower there
we are
and if you just take a look on the right
side
we got rows is the only argument
so in this case we want to say rows
equals gen2 we just want to repeat the
label that's in the step
okay
great so let's run this
great and there's a there's our first
fruit no it's really great so we have as
footnotes often do they have like some
sort of like glyph
like
you know for where the note is referring
to
and there's a note right there so the
footnotes the numbered footnotes they
appear above the source notes
and this is a cool thing we can also
change the way the
the lists themselves we can use alt
footnote marks
and we can say marks could be something
other than like numbers it could be
letters
so if we do that we begin with a
and we can do capital letters like so
and to go even further we could have
like a custom set of
marks so you might do
star
double star
um
you know and who knows we have if you
have any sort of set it will just run
through this set so we do that as well
there we go so you can totally change
the marks to be whatever you want to be
which is
super nice
so that is the first footnote um i'm
going to take this part out just like
demonstrate the order of footnotes so
the cool thing about gt is that you
don't have to like manually manage your
footnotes you can just
go nuts with like you know like adding
tab footnote tempo note and gt will
handle the ordering and like you know
all the other sort of small details when
it comes to footnotes so we can say
things like um
we can elaborate on what say
flipper length is
i mean
we can say footnote
for length
is
i don't know the details about the dsm
or how the data was required uh but we
can say flipper link was measured
with a tape measure it's a little bit
silly here maybe it was who knows but
this is maybe a little bit of fiction
okay so let's say that's true flipper
length was measured with a tape measure
so the note would appear right here uh
on a column label itself flipper length
so cool we can do that we can say
locations
equals
cells and autocomplete user right here
it would be cells column labels this
takes
the columns argument and again we just
put in the column name so i'm going to
type that all out columns equals
uh flipper
good autocomplete again
okay i'm gonna run this
there we are so before where we had one
where gently was now it's number two
because that appears later which is kind
of cool we didn't have to sort of manage
that we'd have to say what the glyph was
um gt does a sensible thing of like
uh indexing footnotes from top to bottom
left to right so we don't have to worry
about things like that
and
here's another really cool thing say for
instance you wanted two footnotes
on the same spot
okay so tab footnote
uh so we'll add an additional note about
this is very silly i'm gonna copy this
whole thing because it's going to be on
the same location
we'll say something like
the tape measure
unfortunately
suffered
some
frost damage
because you know they were natural so
you know things happen uh so yeah maybe
that's you know that to be like
you know disclose everything okay so now
we have like two notes on the same
same column label so what's going to
happen
it seems like some sort of conflict but
no gt handles that you can just run this
we get one and two so it's basically two
notes two different notes
they appear you know a light to this
same cell
and then gen2 is number three which is
great uh but it'll handle multiple nodes
and the cool thing is you can even have
a list
of cell column labels or sorry of uh
locations
so we can have this note being applied
to more stuff
so we can say cells
uh data
or i think it's cells
and we want columns to be the same
column
flipper length
and basically what it's going to do now
is it's going to like denote the glyph
on the column label and all of the
values in that column
so if we run this
you see that two is repeated down
because
you know the tape measure
you know it's compromised so basically
just like putting the the notes
like the glyphs on the actual values
themselves too it's a bit silly but i
just want to show you that like
footnotes it's very flexible
um it does the right thing most of the
time nobody's ever complained about it
which is good news um and i think people
actually like it because
so that is good so footnotes work is
what i'm saying so what if you want to
highlight a certain bit of data
in this table
okay we can totally do that too
we can use tab style
okay
it operates under the same sort of like
principles as
tab footnote
um i mean it has locations
and we use the same location number
functions
so let's say for instance for whatever
reason uh we wanted to like highlight
the entire row of the gen 2 penguin
uh just the data i don't know why let's
say you want to do that okay so we can
do that as we do cells
body
great
we'll use columns equals everything
great
but in this case we want rows to be
limited to just
gen 2
okay this looks odd but it just means
that we're going to target all the
columns
but just the rows and all those columns
that correspond to gen2 not of course in
this stuff when you have something in
the stuff that's an additional advantage
you can sort of like
use the rows argument
more precisely you can actually just use
the labels
uh provide that they're unique
and most of the time they are
otherwise if you like a little bit less
value i'd say
okay great so we have that now we have
the sales body
statement great so now we're going to do
that we're going to actually add a style
great
so we have a bunch of style hover
functions so basically tab style uses
two different types of helper functions
one in locations one style
in this case it's
singular cell
and in this case you want to fill the
cells with some sort of color
there's a default um but i'm going to go
with color
and i'm going to go with like steel
blue i can spell it there we go
and uh let's just see this work so what
i'm expecting to see is the gen 2 row
just the data cells will have that color
in the background
and it worked that's great
so now we have that right there
uh we can change the color it accepts
all color names which is great light
blue i believe is a color that looks
quite a bit nicer
um and we can also use text colors if
you know them
so you can do island of them
let's try it let's try some random one
here let's see if this gives us anything
nice
not bad not bad i just guessed that okay
that worked out pretty well uh but if
you want to say for instance you had too
dark for a color and you wanted to have
a maximize contrast like make this the
text white for instance you can totally
do that you can have multiple styles uh
for the same
location
so we can close that in the list cell
fill is that
and now we can use cell
text
and change the color of the text to the
white
off this i'll just tie this up a little
bit so it looks a bit better
okay so in this case i have the cell
fill color and then using a text color
which is being changed
great
not too bad so now we have like better
contrast because we chose a darker
background color
so that is that uh so you can definitely
do things like style certain cells this
applies to everything you can style the
header you can style the footer you can
style the step every single location
here is styleable
uh one more thing just to complete this
table uh we have this
top left corner here that's customarily
empty i mean the default is that it's
empty but we can change that there's a
special function
just for adding content to that top left
corner it's called tab stub head
and it just accepts a label
and as we often do we can use markdown
to like make that nice
um
and in this case
it's kind of a wild card you can
describe either the columns you can
describe the rows you could describe
both
uh it's up to you i'm just going to put
in penguin so i'm going to treat it more
like a column
so i'm just going to say penguin species
great so i'm going to add that in
and there it is in the top left so you
can definitely use that
once empty corner
and you just have to remember the
functioning tab stub head the little
argument so it's not too difficult to
use go get it
and that's my next table and there's
tons and tons of options
so say you want to change the table font
you can do that with this opt function
called table font this is a pretty
popular option because sometimes the
default font is not what you want uh and
the great thing about this optical font
is you could use local fonts so you have
helvetica on your machine
you can totally use that
and it changes the look
let's say you want something that is you
know not on your machine maybe part of
google fonts you could use google font
then choose like a font from their
service as long as you know the name
it's not too hard to do
so monsterat is one of them now let's
use that
great and it's totally changed and we
have all sorts of options here we have
things like the weight can be changed
usually these are numbered weights so we
can change it to be heavier let's say
600.
there we go so we definitely see that
now
and uh
and you'd have to go to the google fonts
page to see what weight ranges are you
know available
um but that could be totally used
there's options to you like styles you
can choose like italic oblique
um things like that let's actually do
that let's see that
works
there we go so everything was changed to
like the italic version of the font
uh so i'm going to do is i'm going to
take out this tab style thing
for now i'm going to comment it out
because we're going to apply our
style based on data color
okay so data color
this is what i do every time i use data
color it's really hard to use because it
it requires that you use functions
within the function like function calls
and they're not even like gt functions
they're functions from the scales
package
so i would always
use the help and go to data color
like so
and then um of course it tells you
what's you know what it does and
like all the help files it gives you
like some visuals
showing you what it does which are
apparent to the examples but yeah my
point is i would go to the example that
works and then just take it and you know
go from there so in this case what we
have here is it's working on a single
column
um
and we have the colors argument requires
a function call
typically it's not from scales and the
help tells you about this but i'm just
going to copy this in
because it's much easier to show that it
is to
you know explain it beforehand
and what's going to do we're going to
adapt this to our particular example
here so if you look at our viewer again
we have these ones right here we have
columns um right there
so i'm just going to say columns are
going to be
the same as before
so i'm going to choose
maybe for the sake of remedy i'm going
to choose just
fill length and fill depth
great
so now
the colors won't be like those will
basically be colorized according to the
values in the columns so that's great so
we use column numeric to um to create
our sort of like
set of like
colors that we're going to like
interpolate through
so the range is going to be the domain
and we can have this being null and that
just sets the the domain to the range of
the values
but i kind of like actually setting the
domain so i'm going to use c equals
30
and then 50 for the upper part of the
range and then gonna set like maybe
three colors because it's gonna be like
30 40 and 50. so i'm just going to
choose
red orange green and omit the blue
great
great so let's see if this actually
works uh
the key thing is like will this actually
work
okay
it does sort of work uh the reason why
it doesn't work here is because this is
actually out of range
so if you want to have different domains
we can definitely do that with multiple
calls of data color or
we can set this to null
like that and again this domain is
actually inside the scales call numeric
uh function call
so a little tricky but when it works it
works awesome this will be nice because
this will treat each column separately
actually treats it holistically
so
the point being if you just had say like
bill length here this would much be much
more nicer
then we can actually choose the domains
that make more sense for the particular
type of data we have in there let's do
30 50.
there we go so we can see here that the
red is not really
going to be in the picture because we're
pretty far away from 30. we're getting
more close to orange which is sitting at
40. and then green sits at 50 which we
do see quite a bit of chainstrap and
gently but
now we have a template we can actually
do this for each and every column just
tweaking the values of domain
so for instance we want to do this for
bill death
so uh we could change this to be like
something like
10 to 20.
and
we're going to see that as well
basically
there we are
so so on and so forth it does that uh
you can choose even like super dark
colors like if you want to have like
brown for instance what will it do i
think it will actually reverse
the text
if the color is like it will do that for
you it will essentially like
look at contrast and say like oh this
background color is a bit too dark it's
going to flip the text color around
and you can also disable that but it's
just sort of there you can override that
as well with your own sort of like
styling but it's just the thing that
data color does for you and so that's
the way you can sort of like make a sort
of like a heat map for your your table
values and you can keep going on and
there's more functions in column
america's call factor it's all in help
here
um
you know quantiles numeric you know
anything you want you got it it's pretty
nice
[Music]